thanks for staying with us here at 6 30
i'm denise feldas and i'm brian loftis
evictions are up and this is keeping
court busy with cases the i-team
obtained access to eviction court to get
a better idea of what is unfolding
vanessa murphy is live in front of the
regional justice center vanessa
if you get an eviction notice this is
where you need to go and we watched case
after case landlord versus tenant with
different outcomes
this is the final stage of the eviction
process
a lockout
the i-team is here as the constable's
office enters and locks are changed
quickly before the tenant returns
i think we are in a housing crisis jim
burchtold is the directing attorney for
consumer rights at the legal aid center
of southern nevada which has seen an
increase in tenants in need of help the
metro police department reports 800
eviction notices delivered and 395
lockouts in september of 2020 that's
during the eviction moratorium for
september 2021 with no moratorium in
place those numbers jump to 1168 and
1482.
we continue
to talk to tenants every day who still
don't understand what they need to do in
this crisis to protect themselves
some of those tenants end up here at las
vegas justice court
the i-team recently observed
since november as hearing master david
brown handles more than 40 cases on this
day alone i think this is a broke a
relationship is that correct from an
ex-girlfriend who wants to kick her ex
out i still love this woman to a
landlord who claims a tenant is running
an illegal catering business inside a
home
there are lighter moments but mainly
dire situations third time he put a
knife and went after me he called me a
couple of names in the majority of the
cases here evictions
46 denied deny the eviction nevada's
assembly bill 486 halts an eviction if
there's a pending application for rental
assistance through programs like the
cares housing assistance program also
known as chap brown points out several
times ab-486 may have some flaws i
didn't write that law but i'm required
to enforce it it's the saving grace for
many tenants but for those with months
of unpaid rent without a pending
application many evictions are ordered
i'm terminally ill 50 of my heart's dead
in some cases brown grants more time i'm
going to give you
one week to get your application and
everything completed the hearing master
acknowledging on the bench the challenge
to find affordable housing i understand
completely it's hard to find any place
out there right now so
maybe next impossible just another
reason after hearing these words
for many there's a feeling of
hopelessness i don't know
i don't
sorry
we reached out to the chief judge to
request an interview with hearing master
david brown to talk about his experience
in making these decisions a clark county
spokesman got back to us saying that's
not possible because of nevada's
judicial code of ethics even though we
said we wouldn't discuss specific cases
now we have resources for both landlords
and tenants at 8newsnow.com
coming up at 11 we take a look at the
issue of squatters reporting live
vanessa murphy live local now